let's actually use the framework on a
real website here's a mock-up for a
portfolio site that you can use there's
a link in the instructor notes think
about what you learn last lesson about
approaching the process of going from
design to an actual website but instead
of creating new classes and styles from
scratch you should use the classes that
your new framework supports I've gone
ahead and drawn some boxes around
different elements in the mock-up these
boxes correspond with the rows and
columns from the framework which classes
correspond with the boxes in the mock-up
which class would you use for the red
box at the top the blue box at the top
the red box at the bottom and the blue
box at the bottom type your answers in
here